you know the song this land is your land
this land is my land but is it really a
new map of largest companies by revenue
in each state suggests Oregon's should
be renamed the just do it state and
Nebraska is really berkshire hathaway
country because when you think about it
whoever drives the state economy drive
to the state arkansas the land of
opportunity can give thanks to wal-mart
the top earner on the national map for
creating a whole lot of that opportunity
walmart employs nearly 49,000 Arkansas
ExxonMobil is number one in Texas where
oil is still king but some of the names
may surprise you
Costco Wholesale trumped Microsoft in
Washington and the growing Koch
Industries Dustin seeded Sprint in
Kansas creating more jobs but even
Democrats might be thankful for the
country's smallest state not smallest on
this list Rhode Island boasts CVS
Caremark as its top company despite the
ocean state's high cost of doing
business
and while the empire state isn't exactly
known for being a business tax haven
Verizon's empire is expanding rapidly
while calling new york home the most tax
friendly honor goes to Wyoming yet its
biggest revenue generator coal producer
cloud peak energy made just over 1
billion dollars last year still Wyoming
is one of seven states without an
individual income tax so if you're
looking to do something new cloud peak
is hiring